Un año más La misma advertencia cada vez
menos tiempo de reacción
nuestro planeta se acerca a puntos de no
retorno que harán que el caos climático
sea Irreversible
en el centro de la 27 que se celebra en
África la justicia y la solidaridad
climática los países pobres y en
desarrollo piden compensación por daños
y pérdidas
a mujeres y menores nos miran para que
protejamos sus necesidades básicas para
todos nosotros la recuperación depende
de unos recursos que no podemos
garantizar
[Música]
para financiar el mecanismo de
compensación la primera ministra de
Barbados miamotli pide tasar un 10% los
beneficios extraordinarios de las
empresas petroleras Mientras que el
presidente de Francia anunció un grupo
de trabajo conjunto con el fmi y el
Banco Mundial y aseguró que los
compromisos climáticos deben mantenerse
a pesar de la guerra en
no sacrificaremos nuestros compromisos
climáticos por la amenaza de Rusia por
eso los compromisos adquiridos deben
continuar para los países más ricos en
particular el presidente colombiano
también hizo referencia a la guerra
pidió su fin y declaró que el mercado y
la acumulación de capital son la razón
de la crisis climática y que no serán
jamás su remedio además reiteró la
petición al fmi de que cambia los países
en desarrollo deuda por inversión
investigación del cambio climático
claves carbonización es un cambio real y
profundo del sistema económico que
domina es la hora de la humanidad y no
de los mercados
es la hora de limitar el daño Inevitable
tras los acuerdos alcanzados e
incumplidos en las cumbres pasadas